vous avez que guillaume faburel il est
géographe professeur à l'université
lumière lyon ii et enseignant à sciences
po lyon cherchera l'umr triangle et
auteur de l'ouvragé les métropoles
barrabas aux éditions passager
clandestin guillaume faburel merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors les grandes puissances du monde
aujourd'hui affectée par le coronavirus
sont un point commun une vie organisée
dans et autour de grandes villes avec
une forte densité de population
en quoi cette métropolisation du monde a
un rôle dans la pandémie que nous
traversons mais elle a un rôle double a
priori le premier c'est que ce sont les
lieux où il ya les plus grands densité
de peuplement qui n'ont cessé de croître
sur les 30 ou 40 dernières années donc
ce sont des choyé par la densité de
diffusion rapide dont tous les virus et
il ya un deuxième élément
caractérisation c'est que ces foyers de
densité ont pour particularité d'être
constituée autour du mouvement des flux
de l'accélération de la gesticulation à
ses permanents donc au croisement de ces
deux raisons la toutes nos vies et nos
corps sont embarqués dans des réalités
qui fait qu'il est un peu difficile de
ralentir de tempérer de ménager un peu
nos existences
d'où l'idée d'un confinement radical
lorsqu'il s'agit d'intervenir sur ses
flux est sûre c'est densité alors pour
comparer par exemple si la peste noire
au moyen-âge et la grippe espagnole d'il
ya un siècle se sont propagées de façon
beaucoup moins rapide c'est en partie
lié au fait justement que les grands
centres urbains n'existait pas à ce
moment là oui et les centres urbains et
aussi leurs collections c'est à dire que
chaque métropole monde
un peu plus de 130 villes à travers le
monde qui prétendre au label
métropolitain on attend d'entrer dans
les détails mais parmi les
caractéristiques comme hier il ya un
retour du mouvement paraît tout à
l'heure l'idée d'être un point de
collection un opérateur de transport qui
nous permet aux riches internationale
qui nous permet aussi par les grandes
infrastructures de se déplacer de se
déplacer en permanence
donc c'est à la fois l'idée d'intensité
mais j'insiste là dessus donc de la
pénibilité et j'insiste particulièrement
sur du ou des mutations qui ont gouverné
un peu nos existences à nos modes de vie
à nos styles de vie et la question
vraiment du tourisme et des mouvements
joue un rôle assez déterminant lorsque
le comparer au siècle dernier ou ballon
de lainage là ce qui s'est joué c'est en
espace de huit semaines quinze jours on
parle d'eux comme premier foyer
aujourd'hui ça serait new york qui a à
peu près trois mois entre les deux 12 8
km on voit l'activité diffusion à des
mouvements plus que la densité et puis
en quoi le mode de vie le mode de vie
des habitants des grandes villes est lui
aussi un facteur d'aggravation de la
pandémie en comparaison à la vie
proposée est mené dans les zones rurales
il faut regarder chacun dans son
quotidien
mais je défends l'idée avec d'autres que
une des particularité c'est que on a
délégué une date à deux choses qu' il ya
encore quelques années des dizaines ou
des siècles et on pouvait produire par
nous mêmes et qui aujourd'hui va nous
rendre à demander pendant les cent
premières villes de france ont une
autonomie alimentaire de trois jours sur
les questions énergétiques
s'il ya le moins black out eh ben on est
super moment de les faire face à nos
besoins quotidiens reclasse la
particularité la métropolisation sur les
30 ou 40 dernières années dans cette
accélération dans cette densité cette
politique et c'est nous avoir un peu
dépossédé ait les moyens de pourvoir à
des fonctions vitales que son se nourrir
se divertir faire bien et accessoirement
au point que le lancement manière
tragique
respirer c'est ça on a dit la
caractéristique première être dépossédé
de moyens d'action pour faire
directement et du coup quand on regarde
à l'extérieur dans les fameuses
périphérie que l'on a un look dandy
spirit est disqualifié de manière
totalement exagéré puisque c'est une
oeuvre de la pensée dominante dans les
périphéries l'une est caractéristique
première c'est que l'on peut faire
peut-être un peu différemment de sama on
peut produire aussi un peu différemment
en tout cas par l'autonomie à voir ce
que certains des dom une résilience en
tout cas une capacité d'adaptation
double d'être entre parenthèses pour
certains le désir de partir au moment où
la pandémie a été annoncée sur tout le
continent
lui-même a osé oui justement on a vu en
europe surtout en france un seul ce flux
notamment de parisiens d'habitants des
grandes villes partir se réfugier à la
campagne ou au bord de mer
ce retour instinctif inverse les
campagnes comment est ce que vous vous
l'analysez finalement il a nous doutons
fait exister un déclic à ta soif et est
annoncé on avait tendance à se resserrer
et soir à se dilater dans l'espace on
l'analyse de différentes manières
certains vont dire que c'est le
privilège de certains que de disposer
d'un moyen résidence secondaire ou
autres pour pouvoir partir
je rappelle juste à ces personnes là
qu'elle soit 100% anglaise en secondaire
et basson plutôt de la propriété de
classe on peut y ait une guerre donc ce
n'est pas un privilège strictement de
riches
ce qui est certain c'est que dans le
désir et dans le faire
deux sont éloignés c'est d'échapper à un
risque et de se croire de manière
peut-être exagéré fantasmer mais un peu
plus à l'abri dans le refuge des
campagnes que dans le tumulte des
grandes aires urbaines des propos visés
il ya quand même un risque avec sarah
soyons clair ça a été décrit ces que
l'on véhicule avec soit éventuellement
la contamination
voilà donc ce n'est peut-être pas la
chose première à réaliser mais on ne
peut pas blâmer les gens de fuir le
risque est d'imaginer que ailleurs dans
d'autres lieux des espaces
de campagne un peu moins densément
peuplées c'est un doux c'est louise un
peu plus isolé
eh ben on puisse éviter non pas un
compliment parce qu'ils étaient avec par
périphériques qui sont soumis mais le
risque de se voir quand tu es mené et
donc de faire face personnellement
collectivement aux effets du virus
alors avant même cette pause et cette
pandémie on observait dans certains pays
comme la chine que le port du masque
était finalement une habitude une
attitude fréquente dans les grandes
villes
est ce que les habitants des grandes
métropoles en asie avait t'il plus
conscience finalement des dangers de la
métropolisation que nous ici en europe
je sais pas si c'est une conscience de
la métropolisation en tout cas il était
dans des systèmes d études et de
pratiques qui ont rapidement muté à ce
que les villes chinoises ont se sont
développées par les clowns se sont
développées très très rapidement sur les
20 dernières années
aider les habitudes de vie dont celle ci
qui se sont mêmes rapidement avec le
mouvement d'urbanisation et de
densification des habitudes qui elle
même s'était très rapidement prises en
fait c'est à dire un rapport à la
distance un rapport au corps à corps à
vivienne par rapport à la santé publique
les dingues de pollution jamais aussi
grand en chine sur les dix dernières
années d'ailleurs on le voit maintenant
puisque l'activité ralentit a dit anne
meyer fait que la qualité de l'air
s'améliore sensiblement donc des
habitudes ont été prises rapidement avec
un fait métropolitain qui était en fait
tangibles et visibles en temps réel sur
les dix ou quinze anr année alors que
nous aux agglomérations métropolitaines
en europe et en mer du nord ce sont des
villes un peu plus historiques ont des
habitudes ne sont pas celles de
coexistence avec tout ce que cela peut
avoir comme conséquences en termes de
santé environnementale ou de santé
publique
merci beaucoup guillaume faburel d'avant
partagez votre analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes géographe professeur à
sciences po et auteur des métropoles
barbares aux éditions passager
clandestin